قصتها مشاهدينا اذهلت العالم قبل سنوات
سيده اسكتلنديه تدعى
تحمل جينا فريدا تخيلوا شو بيعمل هذا
الجيل بمكنها من العيش بدون قلق بدون خوف
او حتى الم جسدي انا بدي منه تامر البالغه
من العمر 74 عاما لحظه الاطباء بعد عمليات
جراحيه في وركها ويدها انها لا تشعر باي
الم وهو امر غير طبيعي على الاطلاق
الهمت العلماء فبداوا يدرسون حالتها من
اجل تطوير مسكنات خارقه تعمل بفعاليه اكبر
من المسكنات الموجوده حاليا اكتشاف حال
وحاله كاميرون عندما كان عندما حدد فريق
من كليه لندن الجامعيه في العام 2013
متغيرا جينيا يعمل على الغاء تنشيط
الاصدار الطبيعي المتعلق بالتئام الجروح
وكذلك يتعلق بالمزاج انا من هذا بالمزاج
ما ادري خلينا نعمل اوردر انا وياك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات